توصل اوكرانيا الضغط بهجومها المضاد رغم
كل العقبات لاستعاده الاراضي القريبه من
مدينه باخموت والتي تسيطر عليها روسيا وقد
الحقت خسائر فادحه بالقوه الروسيه على
الجبهه الجنوبيه كما تمكنت من تحرير
قريتين قرب بلده بخموت المدمره على الجبهه
الشرقيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اوضحت ان
قوتها تمكنت من التصدي بثمن هجمات في
الشرق بمناطق تتنازع السيطره عليها مع
القوات الاوكرانيه فيما اكدت كييف ان
قوتها تحقق مكاسب ميدانيه حول ثلاث قرى في
جنوب ضخمه
نجحت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في التقدم
من الناحيه الشرقيه لبخموت خلال الاسبوع
الماضي تم تحرير منطقتين اند ريفكا
وكليتشيفكا ومن الجدير بالذكر ان القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه تقود الهجوم مع القوات
المخصصه للدفاع وليس لديهم معدات وموارد
اضافيه
على الجبهه الجنوبيه تركز القوه
الاوكرانيه على السيطره على مجموعه من
القرى في تقدمها نحو بحر ازوف مكبد القوات
الروسيه خسائر فادحه اضعفت قدرتها على
الدفاع يتزامن هذا معه هجوم روسي عنيف على
غرب اوكرانيا بطائره مسيره بالهجوم على
مدينه الفيب حيث سمع دوي انفجارات اكدت
السلطات الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها الجويه
تصدت للهجمات